مساء الخير جسدت من خلال اعمالها الفنيه
التشكيليه واقعا لسوره المراه السعوديه في
المولود الشعبي فنانه تعمل بصمت وتضعوا
بصمتها في كل مشاركه على الصعيد المحلي
والخارجي ومظهورها الفنيه المتاخر فانها
حظيت كذلك بدعوات ومشاركات كثيره شخصيتها
الاجتماعيه المنفتحه على العالم وتقبل
والتحمل ايضا الاخر كما سعد ذلك في خلق
علاقات فنيه دوليه كما يرى الكثير من
متابعها الفنانه التشكيليه زكيه المتعب في
سؤال مباشر استاذه زكيه حياك الله معي
والحمد لله على السلامه نورت الرياض الله
يسلمك خلينا نبدا معك
الان من خلال زيارتك للرياض كيف شايفه هذه
الزياره اليوم
شكرا اولا على الدعوه في قناه العربيه
الرياض ما شاء الله من ازدهار وتطور الى
اخر
وكانها جنه الله في الارض لولا الازدحام
الشديد
ذكيه المتعب لها تجربه فنيه يمكن مختلفه
في الفن التشكيلي السعودي من خلال قراءتي
لبعض من تابعك وتحدث عنك يرون بانه انت
دائما في لوحاتك تركزي على واقع المراه في
الموروث الشعب الامهات والجدات وهذا وجدنا
كثيرا في في لوحاتك
هل في حكايه لهذا الموضوع
تخصصك في هذا المجال واقتصارك عليه باكثر
لوحاتك او اغلبها
طبيعه بدايه الفن التشكيلي اي فنان يبدا
بتعلم
كيف يستخدم ادواته كيف يبدا
الرصاص والفحم ثم الالوان ثم لازم يجب ان
يكون لديه اسلوب يتفرد به
المراه كعنصر اساسي دائما في اللوحاتي
تمثل التراث انا كثير يعني مهتمه بالتراث
والموروث الشعبي تحديدا بالسعودي
لو سالتني لماذا
صراحه خلال شفراتي
تقريبا ب 2008 سافرت الى احدى الدول
الخليجيه
هناك متحف بالمتحف رايت اهتمام كثير
بالموروث طبعا انا بالمنطقه الشرقيه
وكما تعلم
الجزيره العربيه كبيره
ومرت بها حضارات كثيره
تقريبا تشمل يعني المنطقه العربيه من
العراق شمالا الى جنوبا عمان
منطقه حضريه واحده
فتتشابه كثير
وجدتهم يهتمون كثيرا بالتراث والموروث نفس
اللي لدينا لكننا مهتمين فيه ومتمسكين فيه
يعني ما استني شيء من الغيره غير مرضي
نقول شيء تفتقدين وانت على الصعيد الشخصي
ولا شلون
لانه لم يكن هناك توفيق لهذا الشيء موجود
لكن لو ليس له توثيق بالعكس من الدول
الاخرى هذا طبعا الكلام كان في 2008 2009
فعندما بدات ابحث عن اسلوب خاص فيني وجدت
نفسي لا شعوريا نتجه لراسم المراه
والحليها
انتبهت الى انني قاعده ولا شعوريا قاعده
اوثق الموروث
مو انك تشوفي انه مثلا هذا النوع او هؤلاء
او هذه الشخصيات او هؤلاء النساء يعني
اختفينا الان لم يعد لهن وجود كما يرى
البعض مثلا
نحن
دائما يعني سلاله واحده
تتجدد حتى لو يعني لم تختفي تماما لكن نحن
امتدادا لهن
ممكن لما يعني انا لم احتلك الحقبه لكن
بالحديث مع دائما مع والدتي مع والدي ان
الحياه كانت بهذيك الفتره كانت بسيطه اكثر
فالناس كانوا بسطاء جدا كانوا على سجيتهم
شفافين اكثر
كفنان يهتم بهذا الشيء يعني يحسه كثيرا
والعلاقه مع الحاضر من خلال هذه الصور هل
تجد بان هناك علاقه بالفعل بين هذه
اللوحات هناك علاقه قويه
يعني المراه انا لما رسمتها تجسدت التراث
والموروث
الهويه
الهويه حاضره في كل زمان ومكان
ولا يوجد هناك
مجتمع بدون هويه ما شاء الله احنا هويتنا
قويه واصيله يجب ان نعتز ونفتخر بها
المراه لها حضور كبير في اعمالك وزي ما
قلنا المراه في المروث الشعبي المراه ربه
البيت
المراه الريفيه المزارعه من تضع السلال
على راسها وايضا هناك المراه المنطلقه
المراه المتحرره المراه غير المعنيه يمكن
المراه الموسيقيه وفي غيرها كمان كيف نفهم
هذا هذا الترابط يعني بين بين الشكلين
النموذجين للمراه
انه
هويه الانسان تتجدد
[موسيقى]
ويجب احنا نركز على الجانب الجيد منها
فمع مرور الزمن مع مرور الوقت تتغير
تتداخل تتاثر بما حولها
هويتنا تاثرت بعد العولمه بالجانب
بالغرب لكن ما زلنا محافظين على هويتنا
لذلك ترى المراه بهويتها في اعمالي بهويه
وموروثها السعودي والمراه المنطلقه
في وقت الراهن متى بدات تجربتك في عالم
الرسم والفن التشكيلي
شخصيا بدات منذ نعومه اظافري وانا ارسم
بدات فعليا اكثر بالظهور عام 2012 كان اول
معرض شاركت فيه يعتبر حضور متاخر ذكيه
المتعب في فنها في اعمالها
لكل شيء وقت لكل شيء وقت في الحياه نقدر
نقول انه انت بداتي تم توقفت في مرحله ثم
عدتي مره
لو اخذنا هذه المراحل كيف تشكلت وليش
توقفتي
مراحل اول شيء يعني مثلا مرحله الطفوله
كنت ارسم فيها كثير كنت مميزه طبعا
في مدرستي اني من وانا صغيره بيسموني
فنانه المدرسه
الشرقيه
اول ما درست بالرياض
سنه اولى جامعه كان كنت في سكن الداخلي
للطالبات بعليجه كان ما شاء الله لدينا
مهتمين يعني فينا كثيرا كان في قسم
الانشطه فانا دخلت النشاط الفني وشاركت في
معرض
كانت هذه اول انطلاقه لي يعني شفت
فيها ردود الناس
تجاهها اعمالي
وبعدين توقفت
بعد يعني فهذه على طول بعد المعرض انجبت
بنتي الاولى والثانيه بعدها والثالثه صارت
مسؤوليه كثيره وتوظفت والزواج والوظيفه
حددت من
طموحاتك الفنيه نقول ولا شلون ما كان في
حالات صراع بين انه يعني انا شغوفه بهذا
العالم بدي اكمل فيه ولكن هناك ما يعيقنا
يعني المسؤوليات الحياه الاسره وغيرها او
الزواج
اكون معك صريحه لا لا يعني ما كنت كثير قد
ما اكون كنت مركزه على عملي وعلى اسرتي ما
كان في وقت
توقفتيه وبعدين رجعت عام 2012 شاركت زي ما
قلت لحضرتك في اول معرض كان في جماعه
التشكيل بالقطيف شاركت فيه العام الثاني
عشر لديهم
وكان في هناك ورشه تقام
شهر رمضان المبارك يقوم فيها ويعدها بعض
من الفنانين المنطقه الله يعطيهم العافيه
وبعد كده بعد الورشه يقام معرض جماعي فهذا
كان اول معرض تقريبا اقدر اقول فيه لا
جماعي معرض جماعي 2012 معرض الشخصي لا بعد
ذلك اول معرض شخصي كان
في
جون 2012 2018 كان في الخبر 2018
فتره طويله ليه لان الفنان لازم يكون جاهز
قبل اعداد معرض شخصي له لازم يكون جاهز
بادواتها تقنياتها
[موسيقى]
يعني مش اي فنان مبتدا ويبدا معرض شخصي
واهميه قيمه الالوان والريوشه بالنسبه
لذكيه للمتعه
الالوان حياه الالوان هي الحياه
يعني انا اكثر ما يميزني يمكن في اعمالي
الالوان الالوان جميله الحمد لله
ومتناسقه جدا يعني تشوفيها
مع عناصر العمل
حلو ولما تفكر زكيه المتعب في في الرسم هل
تعيش حاله يعني البعض مثلا في الموسيقى
يقول لك والله انا الفنان اعيش بحاله من
الصراع كيف اطلع النغمه كيف
اذهب الى مقام معين كيف احاول ترجمه هذه
القصيده الى الى لوحه غنائيه انت تعيشي
مثل هذه الحاله لما تبداي تفكري في الرسم
ولا الموضوع يختلف هنا
هي كل الفنون واحد ولادتها وحدها صعبه
الولاده صعبه
يعني في حاله مخاض يكون الفنان يعني تبدا
من لوحه ناصعه البياض ثم تضيف عليها
الالوان والخطوط الى مراحل مراحل حتى تخرج
الى
نهايه كما يراها المتلقي فاحنا بنمر بعده
مراحل اكيد مرحله الولاده فكره يعني
الفكره تكوين هل تكون راضي عنها او لا
وبعدين مقياس الرضا يكون من خلالك انت من
خلال الناس اللي تشوف في مقياسين طبعا من
خلالي انا
الفنانه التي رسمت اللوحه ومتذوق او
الناقد الفني خلينا نتوقف معك عند هذه
النقطه وعند فاصل قصير نعود بعده للمتابعه
ايضا الحديث معك استاذه زكيه في مشوارك
الفني حتى اليوم فصل قصير المشاهدين نعود
بعدين المتابعه في سؤال مباشر
اهلا بكم من جديد في سؤال مباشر ضيفتي هي
الفنانه التشكيليه السعوديه زكيه المتعب
حياك الله استاذ زكي في مشاركه لك في
منتدى الثلاثاء الثقافي في المنطقه
الشرقيه قلتي اجد نفسي غريبه عن هويتي
وابحث عنها
اي هويه هذه التي انت ترين بانك غريبه
عنها والتي ما زلت في مرحله البحث عنه
الهويه لو نعرف الهويه ما هي الهويه هي
مجموعه من المعتقدات من القيام من
التطلعات
هذه هي هو انا لكن لما كنت احكي في
المنتدى كنت اتكلم عن هويه الفنيه
بما يعني
اسلوبي الفني هذا الذي كنت ابحث عنه لكن
الهويه الذاتيه الشخصيه هل تجدي انه كمان
هناك اشكاليه في تعريفها اليوم
بالنسبه لك انت كشخصه منك انت تحاولي ان
تتموضع داخل هويه جماعيه موجوده في
المجتمع
هويه الانسان تبدا بذاته ثم
اختلاطه بمجتمعه ومن ثم الهويه القوميه
شيء جميل ان احنا نبحث عن هذه الهويه نبحث
عنها نوثقها
هذا هو البحث والبحث دائم يعني الفنان
يحمل على عاتقه رساله ورساله كبيره
ليس من السهل يعني انه يوثق
تراثه وموروثه يعني انا لا ارسم فقط عبثا
هل تشوفي انه في هويه اليوم للفن التشكيلي
السعودي
الفن السعودي اثبت وجوده في الساحه
العربيه على ماذا تقوم هذه الهويه عندنا
في الفن التشكيلي السعودي دائما بتشوف
مثلا بالفن السعودي اهتمام بالخط العربي
كثير تدخل في الاعمال الفنيه الخطوط وهي
موجوده وهي موجوده ايضا من حرف الخط
العربي خط جميل يعني
انا درست الخط لا اعتبر نفسي خطاطه لا
درست الخط اخذت في دورات لكن
هو جزء من هويتنا وثقافتنا اللغه كتابه
اللغه والحروف
تجانسها في اللوحه في المساحه شيء جميل
وكم راى سعوديه انت كمان معلمه معلمه نعم
قلتي لي يعني قبل الحلقه انه كمان انا
عندي قلق من
يعني من الطالبات او من نظره الطالبات
الجيل الجديد
ليش حاله القلق هذه موجوده عندك
تشبه بالغرب الكثير او
لكل دوله او لكل امه لها هويتها الخاصه
فيها تجعلها قويه ومتفرده
تمازج
[موسيقى]
الحضارات او الثقافات
تمازج ثقافات شيء مهم جدا لكن
لازم ننتبه انه في حد نوقف عنده انه لا
هذه ثقافتي هذي هويتي ما اتعدى يعني ما
ادخل
بقوه
وانحرف في
هويات اخرى انت شايفه انه الجيل الجديد
يبتعد شي ان فشيئا عن هويته نعم قاعد
يبتعد وهل هناك
دور معين يجب ان تقوم به مؤسسه توجيهات
عندنا لمحاوله مواجهه هذه الاشكاليه يعني
جهودها مستمره جميع المؤسسات انا يعني
من المنبر التعليم جدا
مهتمين بهذا الشيء
والحمد لله
رائحه زهره الفلفل والياسمين
الجبل والروزماري
ما كان نكتب بالغي في في حاله الخوف يمكن
شغفي انا وحبي يدفعني للمبالغه بهذا الشيء
ممكن هناك شيء نوع من المبالغه كلامك صحيح
وين مظاهر الابتعاد اللي انت شايفتها كخطر
اليوم
مقلق
مثلا لو ناخذ من ناحيه اللغه كثير بيحكي
لي انا معلمه لغه انجليزيه ليه ما تتكلمين
انجليزي دائما تتكلمين عربي
انه ليه اتكلم عربي انا اهتم بقوميتي
جمال لغتي
فيعني لاشوف الكثير الان قاعد يهتم باللغه
الانجليزيه على اللغه العربيه هذا جانب
حلو هذا احد الجوانب الاخرى
احدى الجوانب جوانب اخرى مثلا
معاها انا مع الحضاره بالعكس ما احب
التخلف ولا ادعو له ادعو الى التمدد
والتحضر
لكن ليس بهذه الطريقه مثلا اذا تكلمنا عن
اللغه الدراسه
اللبس يعني زي ما اقول لك انا الموروث
يعني لما تروح دول اخرى اشياء بسيطه رموز
عندهم يحافظون عليها
احنا ما شاء الله عندنا موروث كبير في
المملكه وفي الدول الخليج ايضا مش بس
المملكه والدول العربيه الاسلاميه
فلازم نحافظ عليه
اليوم المملكه تمر بمرحله
متغيره تماما في تاريخه الاجتماعي
والسياسي والاقتصادي وغيرها من الامور
واساس هذا التغير هو رؤيه 2030 تركز على
المراه في جوانب كثيره
يعني
مبادئ تقوم عليها هذه الرؤيه وكذلك على
الفنون وعلى الثقافات وغيرها اذا كان متعب
كيف تنظر الى اهميه الرؤيه الان في
صناعه الحياه الثقافيه والفنيه
والنظره للمراه السعودي
لنهتم بالشعب
لازم نقوم الشعب بالفن
الفن جدا مهم في تقويم الشعوب
نرفع ذائقتهم تهذيبهم
الله يحفظه الامير محمد بن سلمان كان له
دور كبير في دعم الفن والفنانين يعني يكفي
انه هو الان اصدر او امر بمنع الفنادق
انها تعرض اعمال فنانين اجانب لازم يكون
من فنان سعودي هذا دعم للفنان حتى اللوحات
موجوده في مكتب الخاص اكثر من فنان الى اي
مدى هذا الامر يشكلكم انتم داعم كفنان
اكيد شكلنا دعم كبير فخر يكفينا فخر يعني
انه ولي العهد يدعم الفنانين
بالاضافه الى مسك للفنون معهد مسك للفنون
كثير بيدعم الفنانين ايضا يعني انا اشوف
لهم الفنانين الجيل الجديد لهم مستقبل ان
شاء الله زاهر انت اليوم كمان معلمة معلم
اللغه الانجليزيه ولا معلمة ما شاء الله
مش رسم
احنا لما زمان كنا في المدارس يعني
كانت من اهم المواد
الفن التربيه الفنيه
ما كانت ماده نوعيه لها اي اهتمام
وكانت رسماتنا بسيطه كوخ نهر وشيء يعني
انت بالمقارنه اليوم انت شايفه انه مثلا
كان في تحجيم للفن في المواد المواد الفن
والرسم في المدارس في تلك الفتره هل تحتاج
هذه المواد الى نظره اخرى مختلفه للتعامل
معها في المدارس انا اتكلم بشكل عام
التعليم العام
لا اخفيك امرا يعني بالعكس يمكن في زمننا
احنا كانوا يهتموا بالتربيه الفنيه اكثر
من الان انا تقلصت حصص التربيه الفنيه
يعني من هذا الصرح انه بالعكس تزيد تزيد
الحصص هذي ضائق الفنيه لازم تربى عند عند
الجيل كيف شايفه الدور اللي تقوم
بالمؤسسات
الثقافيه المعنيه بالفن التشكيلي
مثلا عندك لو بنتكلم معهد مسك للفنون
لا دور كبير الان وفعال في الرياض
ويحتضن طبعا جميع الفنانين
وعدد الفنانين بازدياد يعني
الجمعيات جمعيات الثقافه والفنون يعني
يبغى لها دعم اكثر تحتاج الى دعم هي
الجمعيات لتدعم الفنانين
وزاره الثقافه مثلا تعمل دائما
نسميها
بعثات خارجيه
خارج المملكه
للفنانين
الاستفاده واخذ الخبره من الدول المتقدمه
وفي الفن
رساله تفضلي
هناك عدد كبير من الفنانين يبغى يحتاجون
الرعايه هذه انت شايفه يعني انا نفسي بعد
كفنانه احيانا تحدني وظيفتي يعني تجيني
دعوات خارج المملكه للمشاركه في بيناله او
مشاركه فيه ملتقى فني لكن ما اقدر اطلع
لانه ليس لدي اجازه لكن في اجازات في
الديوان الخدمه المدنيه لكل موظف هناك
اجازه خارجيه دوليه يمثل المملكه فيها يجب
ان تفعل هذه الاجازات
انت في معارضك الشخصيه تبيعي لوحاتك تقتنع
تقتنع كم اكبر مبلغ
انا سمعت قريت انه في 2700 دولار لوحه
اللوحات كانت
اكبر مبلغ كان 8000 ريال
كانت لوحه
امراه مع طفل او طفله تحتضن طفله
كانت تمثل لحاله معينه بفتره معينه انا
مررت
عادل
لانه يقول لك البعض لا يعني او يعارض
المساله هذه ممكن التكسب المادي من الفن
لكن في لوحات لا مستحيل انك تبيعيها وتفكر
بعض الاعمال تكون يعني قريبه مني او تمس
شيء مني انت عندك لوحات ممنوع
والرجل ليش غايب عن روحاتك
الرجل مشكله مع الرجل طيب
مشكله مع ابدا ابدا ابدا
كثير زعلت هذا السؤال لكن المراه تمثل
الانسان انا عندي
يعني كلهم
من وين
المراه يعني تمثل الانسان انا بالنسبه لي
يعني ما ماني متحيزه للمراه بالرجل ابدا
من الرجل يعني اذا جينا مساله البيضه ولا
الدجاجه
في بعض الاعمال عندي فيها يوجد الرجل
وبصوره جميله ايضا
طيب أنا
شاكر مقدم للتواجدك معنا في سؤال مباشر
وتمنيات من الصادقه لك بالتوفيق دائما
لانك مرحله جديده دخلتها ايضا كمعارضه
وكلوحات معينه بالتوازي مع هذه الحاله
الفنيه اللي جلسه عيش المملكه سريعه
الحاله ما شاء الله يعني
احنا عايشين سرعه الان
فكانواكب لازم نطور ادواتنا ونطور من فنا
يعني المراه الفن بالسعوديه للان لم يصل
الى العالميه اتمنى ان يصل يوم من الايام
يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا لك الفنان
السعوديه ذكيه
نهايه هذه الحلقه من سؤال مباشر دائما
يمكنكم متابعتنا على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تويتر فيسبوك يوتيوب ومشاهده
هذه الحلقه والاستماع اليها على شاهدوا
على العربيه